У Кремлі запевняють, що опозиційний політик
Олексій Навальний не є небезпечним для чинного
президента РФ, але при цьому не допускають його до виборів.
Сам же Путін робить вигляд, що опозиціонера
не помічає, і категорично уникає називати його прізвище вголос.
Той персонаж, про якого ви згадали, він же
не єдиний, кого не допустили.
Чомусь інших не називають.
Тих, кого ви назвали - це Саакашвілі,
лише у російському виданні.
Як ви ставитися до Олексія Навального,
його діяльності і чому ви не називаєте його
прізвища та імені, коли відповідаєте на запитання про нього?
Я вважаю, що ми можемо мати діалог, особливо
з такого рівня як президентський, урядовий
з людьми, які пропонують конструктивний порядок
денний, навіть критичного характеру.
Чому ж російський президент ніколи не називає
імені Олексія Навального?
Ми звернулися до найвідомішого у Німеччині медіапсихолога.
Путін - дуже досвідчений оратор, і він дотримується
старого, як світ, правила: якщо ви не хочете всерйоз
сприймати свого супротивника, якщо ви не хочете
дати йому шанс, то ігноруйте його або, щонайменше,
не називайте його імені.
Інші теж дотримуються цього принципу, але Путін
довів його до досконалості.
Він не згадує імені Навального у жодній публічній промові.
Він ніби подає сигнал: ця людина занадто незначна,
щоб сприймати її серйозно, я навіть не вимовляю вголос її ім'я.
Втім, багато хто в оточенні Навального вважає, що,
можливо, Путін просто його боїться.
Не знаю, чи боїться Путін Навального, я не настільки
добре знаю його психологію, а за його "покерним"
незворушним обличчям важко про щось здогадатися.
Втім, виникає відчуття, що він справді боїться Навального.
Тому що мимоволі ставиш собі запитання: якщо
Путін думає, що у Навального немає шансу, тоді
чому він не хоче перемогти його в публічному просторі?
Чому він не хоче виграти в нього у чесній боротьбі?
Хто виграє у чесній боротьбі - Путін чи Навальний,
виборці, швидше за все, не побачать.
У понеділок Мін'юст Росії зажадав ліквідувати
фонд Навального "П'ята пора року".
Саме цей фонд забезпечує роботу виборчих
штабів опозиційного політика.